yo a couple of years ago when I was in
Texas this dude was in a kilt in the
front row of my show and I saw his
leprechaun it was the weirdest most
uncomfortable situation I've ever had on
stage I have to admit I thought about
this dude more than I wanted to and when
I got to Texas I got a tip no pun
intended that I might be seeing him
again that night
wait is Kilt dude here right back
are you wearing your Kil I'm not going
to lie to you I got nervous a little bit
you know when your butthole
pckers CU I thought oh that that
leprechaun might come out looking for
his pot of gold again have you heard me
tell the story about the Kil
guy have you heard it that's
him I do love that he's wearing my
merch uh that was a nice touch and I
think we can all agree that this looks
like the type of dude that definitely
would be going nuts
out how you doing dude I am assuming we
we're dealing with the same situation as
we were last night uh of course
yes absolutely I probably don't need to
see your dick twice probably not you
know what but Mama didn't raise no
quitter I I I I felt like I had to tell
the crowd the night the story right so
here you go and enjoy it if you haven't
heard this story
before truly my favorite
interaction with any crowd member I've
ever had at any of my shows we're in
Dallas he's sitting right here in his
kill okay and um I look man if you're at
a comedy show and you're in the front
row and you wearing a
kilt somebody's going to talk to you you
know what I mean you're not you're not
going away unscathed right so he's
sitting here and I was like hey man
and um I said what's with the kill and
he said he wrestles in West Texas you
right and he wrestles and he does a
little circuit and you do the whole
Irish thing right he got a red beard and
red
hair and I said uh
okay thank you for the fact check that
nobody gives a [__]
about one of my favorite and least
favorite things is when people fact
check your
jokes is this a TED Talk is
this thanks for factchecking the fact
that he had red hair and a red beard
very
astute bet you're a lot of fun at
parties that game's actually called
Scrabble if you
know Phil was shitty useless information
uh the shoe was invented in
1727 by the way after the show I did
Google when the shoe was invented and I
was way off just so you know I thought I
was going to be closer but then I should
have realized 1727 we've invented shoes
so this
dude he's
Irish
forever for this story
Irish he's sitting right
here um and he's wearing a kilt that's
the most Irish thing I've ever seen in
my
life but but but he's sitting here and I
said to him I go oh I go so I said are
you wrestling tonight and he was like
nah I was like what's with the
Coke and he he was like things get a
little sticky down here in
Texas by the way if you're a dude and
you're watching
this you know exactly what I mean when
you shake like that and you can feel
your nuts just kind of tap the inside of
your thighs that that is that is exactly
what he was doing right in front of my
face so I was like and but listen man
I need to know so I asked him I go I got
to know dude are
you you wearing
underwear and he said I want to tell you
what I tell everybody else you got to
lift it up to find out by the way I love
the balls on this dude because you know
if you're wearing a kill every single
person that comes across is going to be
like are you wearing underwear so to say
you g to lift it up to find out you
really are
separating the doers from the not doers
do you know
and I told him you're challenging the
wrong
guy are you telling me I can lift this
kill see a human dick and make this
whole room uncomfortable that's my jam
man
like that's what we
like now I will tell you what I really
respect about this dude he never backed
down I kept trying to make him
uncomfortable and he kept trying to make
me
uncomfortable so I he spread his [__]
legs and he was just like get in there
and I was
like yeah get in there was so oddly
confident and nonchalant that I was like
oh no I'm gonna have to see this dude's
dick right now because right away I was
like oh he's not backing down get in
there is not something somebody who's
backing down is saying H so I had to dig
in you you know [__] this guy you
know so but I wasn't going to let him
make me more uncomfortable than I was
going to make him so when he said get in
there I just dropped to my knees and I
was
like and he was like do you have to do
that from your knees and I was like well
from my experience it's the best angle
to see a dick
[Music]
so then he [__] me up again he was
like fine but if you're going to do this
you got to keep eye contact with me the
whole
time yeah he kept winning guys he kept
he kept winning I thought I was like
this is gonna beat him as soon as I
dropped to my knees I was like oh he's
gonna get so uncomfortable he leaned
into
it a hero a true hero this
guy this is not how I saw this planed
out
you so we're just here with this dude
and and I'm reaching for it and we're
just staring at each
other and I was just like now for those
of you with killed knowledge not you but
other
people but for those of you with Kilt
knowledge man there's two sides to the
kilt right one side is more Kilt one
side is Under The Kilt I lifted the
wrong side it was just more
killed and he was pretty funny he was
like you know I bury the treasure on the
other side I
was yeah every time he spoke I was like
oo this is a bad decision on my part
because every time he spoke I was like
I'm really about to see a dick
closeup closeup dick it's kind of like
close-up magic but way
different so I get back down there and I
by the way I look up to look him in the
eye because that's what I promised and
guys I I like pranks so I like to get
people but I I like getting got too you
know and I I grab the Kil and I look up
at him and he [__] B he winked at me
I was
like is not what I want at
all and then I
just yeah real dick human dick yeah yeah
yeah and it was a redheaded situation i'
never seen one of those
it was so much brighter than I thought
it was going to be I'm not going to lie
to you it really did it looked like
something you would have pulled off the
surface of the Sun like wow that is a
weird
red it was a real and it was that color
red where it looked like somebody just
hit it once you know what I
mean like a light sunburn red you know
what I'm
saying yeah dude I'm so glad you're here
this story encapsulates what I love
about being a standup few things one the
story itself man I like it when weird
[__] happens you're not expecting it and
it's life and people two strangers are
just having a weird good time with each
other I also love that yo man you know
I'm a comic you know I'm going to tell
the story but that people understand the
vein in which I'm telling stories there
I'm not he knows I'm not insulting him
and actually he wins the story but I
there's so many things that I love about
it and the fact that he came back and he
reaches out to me whenever I'm in the
area it's so cool to make a connection
like that with some dude over his
dick more of these to come everybody
check out make sure you subscribe to
this YouTube channel share and like and
tell all your friends later